many of you are thinking way too big
you're attaching way too much pressure
on the things that you're interested in
you can have what you want it's three
years down the road you can have
whatever you want
i know you might say brynn that's so
basic but okay did you do it last night
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the five
habits that will stop
your procrastination enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one push yourself to start with mel
robbins
this is a question from vicki vicki
writes i'm trying to become a fashion
and beauty blogger and
mur and earn money from it full time but
i have some kind of mental block
and procrastination problem when it
comes to actually pushing myself to do
anything related to that goal this is
this is something that we hear about
all the time that you have this huge
goal
yet you cannot seem to push through the
mental block that you have something
that you want to do
full time but you can't seem to beat
procrastination
this is something that we see over and
over and over again
and it's this idea that you
don't ever start you stay trapped
in your head and if you feel paralyzed
if you've been spinning the same ideas
over and over and over again
then you know what i'm talking about you
see
many of you are thinking way too big
you're attaching
way too much pressure on the things that
you're interested in
until you start blogging about fashion
you won't even know if you like it so
thinking that you have a dream about
doing it
and thinking that you have this grand
plan that you're
going to do it full time it is a
complete
and utter waste of your time to be
dreaming that big and let me tell you
why
because often times if you're the kind
of person like vicki that's getting
trapped up here
the bigness of what you're thinking
about is what's stopping you
what i want you to do if you're in
vicki's situation is i want you to stop
dreaming and i want you to just start
doing
small things i want you to go back to
curiosity
and less into crushing your big goals
the thing about
life and business and success is that
you
have to be willing to start and for
people that procrastinate
starting is the hardest part for people
that worry for people that think too big
starting is the hardest part folks that
study procrastination talk about the
fact that the only way to beat
procrastination
is to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to
push yourself to get started because all
the research shows that if we can push
you to get
started on something you'll likely
keep going so vicky the only way
to get out of the mental trap is to stop
thinking
and actually start doing it and maybe
thinking that this is going to be your
full-time employment that's the wrong
way to go about it
i want you to literally just commit
to writing some sort of blog about
fashion
every day for a week that's it don't
think about full-time
don't think about the bigness of it
actually start doing it
you may discover you don't like it for
crying out loud but you're never
ever ever going to advance if you
continue up here how do you
force yourself to do it well you can use
the five second rule for that
you can wake up in the morning and say
today i'm committing to making small
progress on this thing i'm curious about
which is fashion blogging
you can find time when you're going to
sit down and then the second that it's
time to do it
5 4 3 2 1 and start writing here's what
you can expect to experience if you're
somebody like vicki
who has trouble getting out of the
thinking loop
the second that it's time to actually
move from thought to action
you will become a first class
[ __ ] you will feel resistance you
will struggle with what you're going to
write
you will start to feel like it needs to
be perfect
you're gonna come up with excuses you're
gonna talk yourself out of it why
well because you're used to thinking and
now you're asking yourself to do
why am i explaining what you should
expect the reason why i'm explaining
what you should expect is because
it's normal to feel those things it's
normal to feel scared it's
normal to feel like you don't want to do
it it's normal to
think about doing it perfect letting
those things stop you is a choice
habit number two visualize with brendan
burchard
here's specifically what i do to make
sure i don't procrastinate i
literally visualize and affirm
what i'm about to go do so
if it's sunday and i'd say okay
you know tomorrow in the afternoon i've
got all these things
i can procrastinate because i'm the only
one holding myself accountable
and i could say well you know what um
let's see here how would i avoid that
i will sit down and i'll do this 20 30
minutes a day
visualizing the next day or that morning
i'll sit down and visualize the day
and i'll just step it through i'll say
okay let me see myself
going into the kitchen getting my little
green tea
going over to the office sitting down at
the computer
opening up that blank page happily
typing along
sensing and feeling those great emotions
of doing my calling
as a writer let me feel the power and
the joy of finishing a great day of
writing
let me imagine myself going to dinner
getting to sit down
with my wife and saying honey here's
what i did today
i wrote this part of the book let me
hear
see and feel that interaction with her
happiness and her joy
that i'm doing my path let me imagine
myself going to bed that night
happy that you know what i did what i'm
here to do
now i don't know what your calling is or
what you feel like you should be doing
but
for me that simple little activity of
just literally walking the entire day
through
not just one thing i do this with with
mega
athletes all the time i say listen i
don't want you to just imagine the fight
i want you to visualize yourself on the
way over to the arena
i want you to see visualize yourself
getting laced up i want you to visualize
yourself
on the walk down to the ring entering
the ring your first feelings walking
around the ring
the sense that you will have as you're
in that fight
that sense that you have when you're
getting beaten in that fight and how
you're going to feel and respond
to that because visualization is not
just happy-go-lucky it's also like
okay see yourself what do you do when
there's a struggle
so i for me okay what do i do when i get
writer's block how do
how does the brendan dealing with
writer's block deal with that
and i'll see it i'll imagine myself
getting back at it
and i'll see it through how does it feel
when you win
how's it feel after the wind how's it
feel at the end of the day how's it feel
when you finally lay
your head onto your pillow and go to bed
that is a full day visualization
on the things that matter the most for
your productivity
and i want you to do that at least
either the night before
or the day of the morning of and what
will happen
these two things together as i know you
might say brain that's so basic
but okay did you do it last night
because
i've found as a high performance coach
sometimes
it is not the big crazy things
it's that people aren't doing the
fundamentals all right my friend
evan carmichael's book listen humans are
built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
habit number three forgive yourself for
procrastinating with thomas frank
we talked about a researcher named
timothy pitchell who's done quite a lot
of research into the subject of
procrastination and one of the studies
that he did
examined the role of guilt and
procrastination and the forgiveness
of that guilt when he surveyed 119
college students he found that students
who took the time to deliberately
forgive themselves for procrastination
in preparation for a midterm exam were
actually less likely to procrastinate on
future
exams so before you get into any of the
other steps in this process
if you are a chronic procrastinator if
you've been kicking yourself for wasting
tons of time
first forgive yourself and it's also
useful to realize that
going forward there is never going to be
a perfect moment to study there's never
going to be a perfect time to do it and
this is one of the stories we tell
ourselves right
we think that in the future things are
going to be better the stars are going
to be aligned and we're going to be at a
much better position
to actually get to work and what you
have to do is tell yourself that
this moment right now it's imperfect
it's not exactly what you want it to be
but it is passable it's enough for you
to get to work and at least make some
progress
habit number four have a vision with
jordan peterson
procrastination and instant
gratification rule me
nothing seems to motivate me nothing
seems to motivate me
what do i do well i'm going to give you
some practical advice
i would say you need a plan like you
need a plan and
not just a plan you need a reason to
implement the plan
you need both of those so something
motivates you you already said
instant gratification motivates you so
you'll do things for instant
gratification
now look instant gratification is a
particular form of reward it's called
incentive reward and it's mediated by
dopaminergic circuitry the same
circuitry that mediates reward
as a consequence of using drugs like
cocaine or any of the drugs that people
abuse
and so there are certain short-term
activities that are pleasurable enough
so they produce uh
an intrinsic they intrinsically produce
a dopamine kick and a lot of that's
instantaneous gratification like
say eating when you're hungry at least
the taste and flavor of the food because
there's also a satiation element that
comes along with food
and so there's those those pleasures
that speak for themselves
when you're looking at the long run
things that are rewards that are delayed
don't produce as much of a
dopamine kick so they're not as
immediately gratifying and they're not
as gripping in the present and
the way that you have to overcome that
is to generate
a vision of it's really it's not a it's
not a plan or a strategy it's a
philosophical vision
that that that that justifies your life
in some way that you
deeply believe it has to be that it and
it can't be trivial because otherwise
procrastination and instant
gratification
are going to rule you so we developed
this program called the future authoring
program and it's part of the
self-authoring suite and i'll run
through it very rapidly because
even if you don't use that program
although you could because
that's what it's designed for and i
think it makes it easier it outlines
what's necessary in order to overcome
the problem that you're describing
so the first question you might ask
yourself is well
what would you need to gain and you have
to have a real dialogue with yourself to
understand this you have to take
yourself warts and all your useless
procrastinating instant gratification
seeking self and you have to sit down
and say all right you know
you're talking to your inner badly
behaved
six-year-old it's like okay what is it
that you would
have to have in order to commit to
something in the long run
what what kind of vision of the future
would
would justify sacrifices for you and you
might say well you don't know it's like
okay
fine that's why you have to break it
down so let me ask you some questions so
you might think well here's some things
that people need in their life
because your life is not going to be
solid
grounded gratifying acceptable
meaningful relevant and
devoid of earth-shaking anxiety without
managing some of these things most
people need an intimate relationship
a long-term intimate relationship
because otherwise they get lonesome
and bored and crazy
crazy in a different way than you get if
you have a long-term relationship
worse crazy they need friends
they need family so that could be your
your birth family your parents
your extended family your siblings but
also children
so you need to to know well where does
that fit in your life what's your vision
for that do you want to get along with
your parents you want to get along with
your siblings
do you have a strategy for that do you
want to have kids at some point
do you want to build yourself a family
okay
you need a job or a career now a career
is intrinsically meaningful
and and and usually very demanding in
terms of commitment and hours
whereas a job at least can be engaging
and worthwhile
um it's usually more time limited maybe
you have more freedom outside of it but
you need a job
because you need something to do and you
need some some routine and you need some
financial support and if you can have a
career and that's what you want so much
the better
but at least at least you could have a
trade something worthwhile
not that a trade can't be a career and
believe me i've got nothing against
trades
um you need to take care of yourself
mentally and physically like
how do you want to present yourself in
the world you know you
you want to be healthy mentally and
physically so that you're
like a light among men let's put it that
way that would be a good goal
how are you going to handle the
temptations of drugs and alcohol and
whatever
procrastination and instant
gratification are tilting you in the
wrong direction
so those are you know seven things that
you might consider
sit down here's the question
you're taking care of yourself like
you're someone you care about
you can design a future that would be
good for you if you were taking care of
yourself
write for 20 minutes you can have what
you want it's three years
down the road you can have whatever you
want but you have to aim for it and work
for it and you have to specify it what
is it what do you want what would make
your life worthwhile what would be good
enough so that instant gratification
would be an obstacle instead of a means
for proceeding
and habit number five the last one
before very special bonus clip
is take action with jocko willing people
want to know
how to stop the laziness and they want
to know how to stop
the procrastination and you know
they have some idea in their head you
know some
kind of a vision
of what they want to do
but they don't know where to start they
don't know where to start it you know
they don't know where to start
and say they say hey where do i start
and and when's the best time to start
and i have a very simple answer for that
here and now
that's it you you want to improve
you want to get better you want to get
on a
workout program or a clean diet you want
to start a business
you want to write a book or make a movie
or build a house
or a computer or put together some
mobile application
where do you start
you start right here and when do you
start you start right now
you initiate the action aggressively you
go
because the idea isn't going to execute
itself
and and the book isn't going to write
itself and the weights
out in the gym they're not going to move
themselves
you have to do it and you have to do it
now
and that means you got to stop thinking
about it and stop
dreaming about it and stop researching
every aspect of it and reading all about
it and debating the pros and cons of it
just start doing it
take that first step
and make it happen
get after it and get after it here
and now now i've got a really special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and how are you going to take action on
it this week when you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action you have a
91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan and when
you
share your plan publicly and have some
accountability you increase your chances
even further of
actually following through so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action
this week in the comments so i can
celebrate
you i like chunking my tasks so that i'm
doing
the same thing once a week and so i film
my videos on tuesdays
every tuesday i'm doing video day i
spend a whole day doing videos
takes me a lot of time every monday is
mentoring day i'm renting the people on
my team
every wednesday is project day right now
i'm working on my book
every thursday is public facing day and
so i'm doing podcast
interviews and hangouts and shows and
every friday is my ceo day
and then on the weekend every saturday
will be
my husband-wife family day like we go
out and we look at a new restaurant
because my wife
loves getting into new food and we don't
do any family admin
zero family admit no shopping no
cleaning up
no whatever something is broken in the
house nothing
and then sunday becomes family admin day
and so then that repeats
and then monday back to mentoring day
and so every single day has its own
assigned task
and yes i'm way more productive because
of parkinson's law
because on a tuesday when i'm making
videos for you guys
i need to get everything done on a
tuesday writing to get it all done
otherwise we won't have videos for the
channel and i haven't missed a deadline
in years and so it forces me to be
massively productive and i have to make
enough videos for three times a day
times seven days of content
it's a lot of content it's a lot to get
through so i gotta i gotta be snappy we
gotta make it happen
okay so that's typical parkinson's law
there's two other main benefits to it
that i think most people miss
the first is the energy difference and
so
when i'm getting into youtube video day
i had to put on a special kind of evan
because naturally i'm introverted
so this i have to i have to get up for
i've got to summon
the inner evan bold speaker man
to come out and make these videos
because it's not my natural my naturals
to be quiet to be introverted to look at
my computer
and not talk into a camera when i'm
doing my book writing day tomorrow on
wednesday
i'm introvert mode i don't want to talk
to people i don't want to do anything
else i'm just focused on getting my
thing done
when i'm doing mentoring mode i'm i'm a
different kind of evident and so you
lose energy when you're switching tasks
not just the typical advice that people
give you where
you know before a phone call you're
spending 15 minutes and you're not very
productive
before that phone call and so like jam
your phone calls one after another after
another after another so you're not
wasting time looking at what you're
doing next and it's true like the
20 minutes before phone call is
massively unproductive time so like
batch everything my thursdays are packed
all the way through
with calls and interviews and schedules
it's not just that
it's not just the fact that it's a it's
a time difference and that people are
sucking your time going from task to
task and that you forget
what you are working on and if you're
working on a book and
somebody interrupts you that
interruption means you're like have to
get 20 minutes of just
thinking back to getting to where you
were it's that you're a different person
when you're doing different tasks
different tasks require a different
piece of you and so
making these youtube videos requires the
extrovert heaven that comes
out it requires the thought leader evan
to come out it requires a lot of
my energy to make this but it's a
different kind of energy than when i'm
doing
my mentoring that i did yesterday when
i'm writing my book and so it allows you
to stay in the same energy zone
for the day which i find massively
productive i think when you have to
switch your energy from one to the next
it really sits you back and it's really
hard to stay productive
and so if i'm looking for you i creating
a day per week
i look at what is the energy that i need
for this day and i could just be that
person for this day a piece of you
it's not like you're faking trying to be
somebody else it's definitely a piece of
you
but then you don't have to switch from
that piece to something else if i had to
do an interview and then do a video and
then write my book
and then mentor somebody it's too crazy
it would be massively unproductive
because the energy has to switch too
often so staying in the same energy zone
every single day when you've got your
schedule makes it really important
and then the last thing that nobody
talks about that i think is really
important with this when you set up a
day a week
is i miss it i miss it like it's good
i think it's good to miss your work and
so today's youtube filming day for me
it's gonna be crazy i'm making tons of
videos today it's overwhelming it's
amazing it's awesome and stretchy and
i'm building i'm growing
right amazing and then by tomorrow it's
like i don't want to look at making
youtube videos
i'm done i don't want to make youtube
videos i'm going to go deep
introvert mode and work on my book and
that's gonna be amazing
i'm gonna spend the only day that i have
in the week to work on the book so i
have to get a lot of stuff done there
but then come saturday i start to miss
it it's like ah you know i can't
i can't wait for like when's tuesday
coming around and then sunday's like
it's building up and then monday's like
man i can't wait like tomorrow's youtube
day is amazing
and i think when you're always
constantly 100 of the time doing the
same thing especially as an entrepreneur
over and over and over again you start
to get bored you start to hate it it
starts to become monotonous it starts to
you want to have variety in your
schedule
and so i like having one day to do
one different thing each week i like
having tuesdays my youtube day because i
miss it
because i look forward to it happening
again and when you look forward to what
you're doing
and that happens every day like right
now i'm missing my book i haven't
written my book for a while like
tomorrow i can't wait i'm pumped i want
to go write my book
right and then the next day i can't wait
to do my main i haven't done interviews
for a long time
so i'm pumped to go back and do that and
so i think when you can design
your calendar where you start to miss
stuff i think it makes it really
important so
if i'm you what i'm looking at is how do
i set up my schedule i'd open up my
calendar
make sure your actions map to your
ambitions outline what all your goals
are in life and your goals should be
habits
not like i want to reach you know x
million of whatever
it's the habits like if you look at the
habits that are in your calendar if you
did those things
would it help you accomplish your goals
if you just say consistent on your
habits
that's the most important thing because
you are what you consistently do
and so plan out your week and put put in
your personal stuff too
like i said we made the commitment that
saturdays is not going to be family
admin
day i'm not reachable it's me
family all in doing festivals
going out for dinner fun stuff so plan
out your calendar
and try even if you just pick one day
try to say this day
i'm gonna block out so i can keep it
open to do
this main task i want to get this thing
done
and feel the productivity that comes
with it and feel the happiness that
comes with it and feel the energy that
comes with it
it'll it'll be one of the biggest
changes that you make if you think that
you are not
productive this is the hack this is the
best way that i know of
of how to stay productive stay on track
making sure that you're accomplishing
your habits and those habits lead to you
accomplishing your goals
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
even more advice on how to destroy your
procrastination check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there